wir haben Ostern und hier steht immer
noch mein Weihnachtsbaum in meiner
Wohnung es ist so peinlich ich weiß
nicht wie das passieren konnte bzw
eigentlich weiß ich es ich habe die
ganze Zeit die Augen offen gehalten nach
Weihnachten so im Januar waren die
anderen Leute ihre Bäume nach draußen
stellen aber es ist einfach nicht
passiert es muss in dem Zeitraum gewesen
sein als ich zufällig nicht zu Hause war
also nicht in der Stadt war und ja das
mache ich jetzt ich habe keinen Garten
hier im Haus wo ich den einfach
verbrennen könnte
ich wohne mitten in der Stadt ja er
nadelt was würdet ihr machen ich drück
mich einfach davor lass ihn stehen aber
das ist ja keine Lösung